that's the place to be do all the party
around brazil
[Music]
[Applause]
i felt like a princess that fell off the
tower so we went from this to this
you love it or what's your feeling
everyone has maids this is what i've
heard what could the u.s learn from
brazil
[Music]
oh it's fantastic out here guys
good afternoon guys my content is about
different people
different cultures different
perspectives in this world
the moment here in florida and i've been
introduced to a woman named
anna anna is from brazil and i'm curious
do brazilians here integrate into us
culture
easily do they live in their own
separate
universe i know that's not a one size
fits all
but we're going to get a little glimpse
today we're going to get a sliver of
brazil in the united states
i know we've all been locked down most
of us have been locked down
not traveling internationally so today
is a nice little
window into the brazilian world with
anna
here in miami should be fun
let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
nice to meet you yes nice to meet you
whatever we're doing
hi peter what's the brazilian community
like here in miami because miami from
this is my second time but what i'm
realizing more this time is it's
everyone here in quantity
especially like the latin world right
like there's a huge venezuelan huge
cuban
yeah huge haitian population yeah
brazilians do you guys make are there
many brazilians here are there a lot or
yes there are many brazilians and the
thing about
i live in miami right i personally live
in miami and they everywhere
in miami um in miami they are
they're not a specific brazilian
neighborhood per se okay
there are specific neighborhoods in
south florida okay but they're up a
little bit up north of miami
okay we're we're going there right yes
okay cool
we are gonna go there and uh we're gonna
experience
what it is the people that like to leave
the country but
still live like as if they were never
like left
right so is that like how long have you
lived here in the states
oh in total in the states like 24 years
okay so a long time
do you have you integrated into u.s
culture or do you stay with brazilians
mostly
uh i stay mostly internationally okay
with international
i have friends from all over i love the
flavor
i learned so much and the boston taught
me that you're saying something very
right because like
in florida especially miami yeah south
florida
it's a it's a diversity but it's a
diversity of a lot of like
latinos venezuelans brazilians
argentinians
yeah in boston it's more like you see
ethiopians
you have a big chinatown right you have
russians
although you do have russians here and
also in uh yeah
i haven't seen any chinese though at
least around here
well they actually buying land here in
florida but more like
on the west side and uh but it's not as
predominant as new york
and then like in boston for instance
more in new york even
if you feel like eating armenian food
you'll find it because there's a
convenient
neighborhood in boston as well here no
it's here's more like an extension of
south america
so what's the biggest lesson you've
learned here living in the states you
can take it any way you want
and you're not gonna offend me i don't
think we'll offend the audience
some people of course but that's just
how the internet works
but what would be the biggest lesson
you've taken away from me it's really
not taking things personal it's like
for instance like um the first place i
lived my adult life
was in boston like i went to work there
and so in my work um
ethics i came to age in massachusetts so
as an adult i came to age
in the united states sure and
it's we go down to business and then we
don't take personal if i'm talking to
somebody about
how the performance will work they
understand it's about the performance
and not about the person
okay we let things we tend to take
things more personal
taking it to the heart yes and i and i
experienced that first thing
when i moved from massachusetts to here
because at that time i was
looking for jobs and i would get a job
if i applied for in boston like
very easily right on the interviews i
would do well
right but in miami because i was just
like i'll get the job i got it done and
this and that and it was not flying
because i was not having conversations
you know okay
okay i was not sitting there and smiling
and talking about
like oh i wish you oh how was your
weekend
and so you're saying the latin world
rubs off on the culture here
yes yes absolutely brazil it is a big
barbecue culture but we are going to
experience something called feijoada
with a typical dish from rio de janeiro
okay
and the way it was created is beans
it's the basis beans it has a whole
bunch of fun sites
okay like oranges vegetables
but um there's an interesting aspect
behind that dish
which is that dish was actually created
by the slaves in brazil
because they would kill the cows for the
principles of the farm uh-huh but they
were not allowed to eat the good part so
only you were left with
feet or the head or parts that the house
didn't want it
the main house didn't want it so
that they put that all into the beans
and made a stool
okay yeah and uh in this restaurant they
even serve in a clay pot
oh cool yeah we just cook slowly because
you remember they only eat the parts
they can't even bite
because of feet think about eating like
a food are we eating feet and
all the parts oh no we changed it since
then okay now we're having the
we have in the feijoada the beans for
the good parts
okay cool
[Music]
brazilian restaurant and we're in a
non-descript neighborhood just off a
highway
but this is this is the real deal yeah
yes we got crock pots
yeah that's the clay pots we're talking
about after year
all right i mean clay pots yeah is this
brazilian style where you do like a
buffet
is this this is the freshwater that we
are talking about
and it's all the size that comes with
you're very religious yeah okay we have
a little catholicism here
[Music]
you have some greens
chicken pork okay
beef stew ribs
sausage
[Music]
this is plain black green right the base
of the stew is black beans
okay so this is a plain black beans
usually we use
a lot of garlic in brazil and this is
the one that was telling you they used
to be made
of the leftover parts yeah i'm not
waiting for you
okay good cheers
thank you
[Music]
that's nice it's weird no it's nice
pineapple and mince
because i i left brazil in a very
traumatic event
like my life turned upside down
emotionally financially
everything right i was a super shelter
growing up i was
my late 20s and um
so what what what was the catalyst for
you moving like why did you move
that was it um i was very pampered
sheltered and i lived a great life
everyone has maids this is what i've
heard yes is this true
oh yeah like what middle class up has
made
yeah yeah i had a car since forever
since i could drive
i had a maze that goes there every
they would leave with us every day we
had a pool we had a mate that goes there
once in a week to do like a half year
[Music]
cleaning right we had uh somebody that
cleans the pool you have somebody takes
care of the garden
and i i see the american families which
is very nice the children
well at least by my experience the
families that i post to here in america
the children
are raised to learn to clean after
themselves
as soon as they get up they're supposed
to set their beds up
they're supposed to wash their dishes
right
they have shores they have
responsibilities that's
very good for the character
and that translates into how we present
ourselves in the world later in life
when we're working and or even in a
relationship
because now we're not expecting somebody
else to pick up after ourselves
so you had to learn that in your later
20s yes
and it wasn't fun it wasn't fun at all
why did you did you have some like
temper tantrums or
some oh my god i was just oh it's super
hard
i used to sit down and i'm like
and um yeah and i was like
okay i felt like a princess that fell
off the tower
now it was just like cinderella or
something like scrubbing the floors
that's some tough love
and i remember to remember if i closed
my eyes they gave me the brew
and the like the soap or whatever and i
got okay now go clean the bathroom
that put me down my place
so how long did this period last where
you were like
had to recondition i guess yourself
change your habits
well when you get yourself that you need
to do you need to
do it you do it that's one of the things
how i learned my english
i was in boston massachusetts and i
wanted to have a
quality life and i wanted to interact to
the police that i was living in it
and uh in order to get a better job
because i told you i started as a boxer
in a restaurant because i didn't speak
english
even though i went to school you can
imagine from a princess
that i thought it was what didn't say
[Music]
somehow i had to stay through it and
polishing it just like
polishing it it's like yes there's
something better than i am right now
because i wasn't happy either deep
inside i wasn't happy either to be
like somehow shallow as it was
because that wasn't really my assets i
was just going with the program that was
presented to me
so you know like you know what's
interesting and i think
quite often is there's a lot of are a
lot of entire there are a lot of people
down and out in the states there are a
lot of people that work very hard but
they're also a lot of entitled people
title mentality so i wouldn't think it
would be someone from brazil
saying they came to america to do the
hard work
right and back home it's it's easy it
was easier remember
it was easier yeah oh and it was easier
back then in the 80s
well yeah but what happened on family
went to uh my father went to bankruptcy
so we lost
everything and he didn't tell us until
super late
so your family lost everything yeah so
we went from this to this
and then at the time a friend of mine
was visiting from boston and she was
like why don't you go
with me i just wanna easy way for me was
the easy way out i didn't want to deal
with
it and i didn't want to have to explain
to my
society my friends over there
why was happening so it was like escape
i escaped
but i escaped to find myself i i didn't
know i was capable
of myself so that journey is
you wouldn't you wouldn't trade it for
anything right oh sometimes i probably
would no
yeah no yeah but
but i i show up i showed up i feel like
when life our life calls we showed up
it wasn't really super easy because i
learned like
in boston people asking me a question
and i would tell a story because we love
telling stories
and they would interrupt me they're like
no
yes or no so i became i was polishing it
it's more direct it's more direct
yeah so i start blending myself from
your experience what would you say the
u.s
in general obviously it's a massive
country you can't just say for everyone
but generalization
what could the u.s learn from brazil
culturally
like what look at that what does it what
is the state's lacking on
i like the way we really believe in the
magic
of life in brazil
uh as i was talking about we are
mystical and
we believe in the spirituality more than
here
we believe that more in the energies
more in like really
the contact with nature i think a bland
from those two worlds it's beautiful
it can be very like cool this is what
i'm making my own land
which is what i learned from we need to
know where we are coming from
in order to know where we're going so i
started learning where i'm coming from
where i'm at and where i want to go and
i want to get the
my best stew from the feijoada for
instance the vegeta of life
yeah which it was good by the way that
was very tasty yeah very good
though very rich
so would you say brazilians typically
are they just
um let life flow better they don't they
don't stress as much
about things down the road maybe they
let it flow or they
they more flow away yes
you're in miami but teca is the this is
the local local place right this isn't
where the tourists go
this is the authentic tuck away right is
the way yeah
tucked away yeah okay anna where are we
off to next
well now we're gonna get a flavor of the
brazilian
community
[Music]
it's an original name yes rio de janeiro
right rio's meeting grocery we're gonna
go see what i'm
missing from brazil some products
oh this is good actually let's say
you're
when i was a kid brazilians love
barbecue right and they have a way of
cutting the meat
okay special ways there's different cuts
right and here
and i'm sure they do the brazilian cuts
here
brazilian cuts okay that's the brazilian
cup
this is uh curated this is very typical
from the northeast of brazil
actually your food is very much
regionalized right
what what is this it's like an ice cream
cone but no ice cream
color no no it's chocolate is it just
chocolate
chocolate is the brazilian population
increasing what's the story with the
brazilians around here
oh yeah they're increasing increasing
okay
and they all come to this year i was
surprised how many more brazilians there
is down here in florida than
the north it's like uh yours is more
spread out right
no i think it's more concentrated where
are we going right now
i think about it yeah they
yeah they just reopened barracuda
because they closed the original one
oh really i didn't even know there was a
region i'm saying
what no pro she i she's my brazilian
guide
and uh that they had one and then they
had to close down because
there was a lot of complaints they used
to do like uh
they closed the uh the park down because
the brazilians their parties were too
loud
they were planning to laugh especially
the weekends there was pagodas
outside that sounds like right but then
they reopened they opened another place
close to it yep very close to them yeah
so and they still have pagodas but
there's more like
inside now it's not okay okay but there
there's gonna be a party there today
maybe they'll be they'll be okay cool
yeah yeah there's a party around
brazilian do you know these
oh serena yeah that's a
real brazilian chocolate all right shall
we friend i hope you're all good
thank you come back take care ciao
all right let's give these a try here we
have the uh
saranat something de amor
something of love
chocolate nougat a little crisp
very good very good then we have the
blast how is it oh yeah
[Music]
it's got like um it's like a caramel
sort of chocolate combo in there there's
a crisp
hard chocolate soft chocolate caramel
brazilians are doing it right with the
desserts here that's for sure
[Music]
deerfield beach
quite interesting place guys we're about
uh an hour north of miami
and i guess the biggest brazilian
community
in south florida quite a wild place
beach scene going off so what were you
saying in the car you're saying
brazilians are inclusive
yeah that's something i really
appreciate about my culture
how inclusive we are like we have a
birthday party
uh-huh we like to have the whole
neighborhood to come and celebrate with
us
so what do you mean someone's walking by
your house and you invite them in
no because you don't move much you grow
up you pretty much live in
the neighborhood that you grow up with
yeah you invite
your neighbors the neighbors of your
neighbors so the whole buyer
will come
this is the place to be though for
brazilians in usa right
that's right all right that's the place
to be
how long you live in the us for
about 15 years okay how is it
good amazing it's cool yeah it's been
good to you
big time and you got all your friends
and people from home here
family everybody good stuff
take care take care enjoy
you see how he said hi to me yeah i was
telling you about that
yeah yeah yeah i said like how we were
inclusive how we how we recognize people
like
i believe in miami for nine years which
would like away
an hour like 40 minutes and i'm so
thankful you peter for bringing me to
this like
memory reconnecting lane because
it's something that i've been wanting in
my heart and these
you and your everybody is just here
and i'm doing this like live i'm doing
this for a lot of people to watch so
i feel like i have a lot of company
and it's just the the vibe here what's
up man what's up
everyone look at those smiles look at
these smiles they look at they
they look at you in the eye bright
smiles it feels free
it's alive you needed this yeah
thank you and being the the two people
wearing masks out of thousands
isn't working uh so the mask has come
off
uh i came when i was 13 so it's been 20
years
oh wow yeah
you love it or what's your feeling i
always wanted to play this but i never
did i never had the chorus right so one
day i was like you know what i got a
couple of friends i didn't know how to
play either yeah not to get embarrassed
and we started with the other quarter
watching the good guys play right
after a while six months you become a
little better i would say so we became a
little better we joined together and now
you know i can't miss it it's like if i
miss it's like i start getting sick
i gotta get out of the house come play
it's that serious so i want to bring the
audience into this because uh
anna is my guide today and she's
fantastic and we had great food and we
checked out miami a little bit
good but this is her first time up here
right yes
and how how do you feel how do you feel
about it like what's your take on it
no worries you know
yeah when you don't you know i feel so
awesome
so vibrant and uh it's a great energy
right
it's fantastic out here yeah it's about
the energy so it's hard to translate it
i would take this over anything i've
seen in miami beach
personally from my limited time in
florida we can't do both
but you can do this but this is like
more of it's interesting because it's
not as packed as usually it's because
the quote right
yeah when it's you know hotter when it's
summer really summer
this place gets amazing more than that
yeah more than this right now it's calm
to be honest it's not as you know as you
used to be
because of the we know it's cold day but
the sun came out a little bit
we still come out that's how you know we
enjoyed it so much
yeah that was cool
that was cool yeah say something buddy
yo subscribe to this app
right here thank you
yeah all right guys bro
is this like a a pedal biking gang
what's going on here
that's what you call yourself what's the
name of the crew tbr
tbr take a big risk take big risks
dude are you pumping uh you lifting
houses at night what's up guess how old
i am bro how are you younger than me 14
bro you're 14.
if you're on my hockey time team you
would have killed everyone
keep on grinding yeah they're pretty
they're pretty talented
huh oh talented again you get life in
your hands my god
having your tick tock tell me what
happened got taken down why because
i posted a video of some kid falling on
their bike
and tick tock doesn't like that so they
took my video down but they took they
they totally killed your account for
that yeah so i reposted it on my new
account this is my new account
broward.tyler underscore official tyler
you don't give up do you
no i keep up the grind you keep up the
grind
if they take this one down i'll make a
new account i don't stop the grind don't
[Music]
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
well guys end of the road a little bit
of brazil
in the united states and anna was the
hero she brought us into this and
you even got something out of it
yourself and
if you want to see anna's website she
does some very interesting work
it's called biosacred.com
check it out you specialize in in reiki
uh yes transformational intuitive
coaching
transformational intuitive intuitive
coaching yes
okay guys thanks for coming along until
the next one